[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
émission de checkup votre magazine santé
et bien-être ce mois-ci nous allons à la
rencontre de Nathalie depuis un an elle
bénéficie de l'aide du Samsa un service
d'accompagnement pour adultes handicapés
récemment installé à plaisir nous
évoquerons également l'histoire de Tibo
ambassadeur du tééton 2013 ce jeune
garçon de 5 ans est atteint d'une
maladie rare qui touche un enfant sur
10000 en France nous irons aussi à Manil
et àot un nouvel espace est réservé au
malades d'Alzheimer ils peuvent s'y
détendre dans un cadre assez surprenant
mais tout d'abord le premier sujet le
cannabis médecins et association sont
unanime sa consommation est dangereuse
et ne doit pas être banalisée nous les
avons rencontré à trappe lors d'une
journée de prévention
reportage la France championne d'Europe
de consommation de cannabis chez les
jeunes les médecins et associations ont
insister sur ce point la moitié des
jeunes de 17 ans l'auraient déjà
expérimenté lorsqu'il est consommé avec
l'alcool les risques se multiplient la
prise de cannabis lorsqu'il y a de
l'alcool associé va augmenter cette
prise puisque le cannabis donne soif et
donc on va encore plus consommer de de
l'alcool par ailleurs le cannabis induit
des problèmes de jugement donc on va
être incapable de se rendre compte un
petit peu de ce qu'on fait et donc il va
y avoir un effet boule de neige entre le
cannabis et l'alcool et donc de
multiplication des risques et des signes
d'ivresse phénomène de groupe simple
amusement le cannabis séduit surtout les
adolescents des adolescents parfois
lasser des discours moralisateurs sur la
consommation pour Jean-Paul Manaranche
il faut promouvoir d'autres pratique de
sensibilisation travailler sur l'estime
de soi travailler sur les affirmations
travailler sur l'esprit critique voyez
et pas uniquement travailler sur ces
produits pour un N d'entre eux je vous
dis ils peuvent plus l'entendre c'est
tellement ils en je dis entre
guillemetsbol quoi aucun médicament ne
permet pour l'instant de lutter contre
la dépendance le meilleur conseil des
médecins dans ce cas-là c'est de ne pas
rester seul c'est surtout de se faire
accompagner dans des structures
pluridisciplinaires où il y a des
médecins et des psychologue pour pouvoir
prendre en charge le patient dans sa
globalité et l'aider voilà mais il
existe pas de médicament et pas de
substitut au THC ciblé vers s suragees
le cannabis est toujours illégal en
France toute personne qui en possède
risque un an d'emprisonnement et 3750 €
[Musique]
d'amende le Samsa existe depuis 2008 ce
service a pour vocation d'aider les
adultes en situation de handicap à être
maintenus à leur domicile auparavant
implanté à voisin le Bretonneux la
structure vient de s'installer à plaisir
c'est là que nous avons croisé Nathalie
une des bénéficiaires du
service nathalie est un peu stressée
dans quelques minutes elle devra faire
un discours pour l'inauguration des
nouveaux locaux du Samsa mercredi
dernier on l'a préparé avec les avec
certains
éducateurs vouszis cur non j'ai oublié
maintenant mais en plus je vais être
obligé d'avoir ma feuille avec moi parce
que je l'ai même pas je même pas
travailler dessus je suis franche en
plus j'ai même pas
travaillé Nathalie fait partie des 20
adultes handicapés qui bénéfici du Samsa
tous les mardis elle reçoit un éducateur
à son domicile pour l'aider dans les
tâches quotidiennes notamment pour les
courses c'est un soutien et surtout pour
quand c'est pour les courses moi qui a
pas le droit de porter Mo ça m'a pour
moi quand c'est bon je dis quand c'est
un homme pour moi ça me fait une charge
en moins ici avec son assistante sociale
elle demande de de l'aide pour quelques
démarches
administrative le service a pour
vocation d'aider les personnes en
situation de handicap à être maintenu à
leur domicile médecins éducateurs
spécialisés ou encore infirmière
apportent soutien et suivi dans
différentes démarches on compte deux
Samsa au sein des Yvelines dont celui-ci
qui vient de se délocaliser à plaisir il
propose un accompagnement différent
on peut rester chez soi être handicapé
et bénéficier d'un accompagnement
multidisciplinaire voilà aller faire ses
courses aller au cinéma accéder à la vie
socioculturelle aller au travail et
continuer à rester chez soi avec sa
famille ses
enfants voilà pour certaines
personnes c'est l'heure du discours
devant l'Assemblée et le maire de
plaisir naalie reste très
concentré j'ai de référents au SAM qui
on pour rôle de m'accompagner dans mes
projets cela me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
convient thbao est atteint d'une maladie
rare une maladie due à un gène déficient
qui empêche ses muscles de fonctionner
normalement avec ses parents il a
accepté d'être l'un des ambassadeurs du
Téléton 2013 il nous en parle chez lui à
Triel
surcè
thbao a 5 ans il est atteint d'une
maladie rare l'amotrophie spinale elle
touche environ un enfant sur 10000 en
France et empêche les muscles de
fonctionner normalement
ça don peur cette année avec ses parents
l'ivelinois fait partie des C familles
ambassadrices du Téléton et il a déjà
quelques scoupes à nous livrer il para
qu'il nous amène dans un endroit a des
jeux et accessible pour les
fauteuils scolarisé dans une école
traditionnelle Thib est accompagné d'une
auxiliaire pour ses gestes du quotidien
à la maison tous les jour c'est aussi 3
qu heures de soins avec les parents et
le kiné des journées bien remplies mais
pas de quoi épuiser le jeune garçon
toujours très
positif c'est des trains de rus les gens
sont souvent étonnés quand ils le voi
arriver quelque part avec un grand
sourire il nous demande mais mais il est
heureux et oui on peut être handicapé et
heureux alors si vous voulez j'ai trouvé
des marrons des Maron dans mon école il
est tellement positif combatif qu'il
essaie de tirer profit de de n'importe
quoi et puis ben finalement il va
s'entousiasmer des des petits bonheurs
de la vie et donc c'est ce qui fait
qu'il est qu'il est heureux et qu'il
profite malgré tout des joies des
enfants de son âge et comme tous les
enfants de son âge lui aussi rêve de son
futur métier ah oui en plus j'en ai
trois et c'est quoi ce métier Bura avion
ah oui d'accord va falloir choisir ah
oui c'est l'un des
trois actuellement aucun traitement ne
peut le guérir le gêne déficient a été
découvert dans les années 90 mais il
faut maintenant que les chercheurs
trouvent le moyen de le reprogrammer les
parents de thibo il croit ils espèrent
que les recherches aboutiront avant son
adolescence mais il faut faire vite très
vite car la maladie est évolutive et les
contraintes de son handicap vont aller
en grandissant oui on est
optimiste mais ça reste quand même une
course contre la montre ce qu'on
souhaite c'est
que la recherche puisse déboucher
aboutir le plus vite possible de façon à
ce que on puisse au moins stabiliser sa
sa situation
cette année encore des milliers de
bénévoles du Téléton vont tenter de
récolter un maximum de dons pour la
recherche le weekend phare de l'action
est prévu les 6 et 7 décembre prochain
tu peux descendre papa oui je peux
descendre oui
[Musique]
merci c'est une pratique initié au
Pays-Bas dans les années 70 les espaces
snowzolon permettent aux malades de se
détendre en stimulant les cinq sens une
salle vient d'ouvrir à Manil àot elle
est notamment réservée aux malades
d'Alzheimer un reportage d'Olivier Manis
calco et de Jonathan
villman fin septembre se tenait
l'inauguration d'un espace snow theelen
au domaine du manté à Manil les hameau
cette salle de relaxation et de
bien-être propose un accompagnement
complémentaire aux personnes souffrant
de la maladie d'Alzheimer ou d'autres
handicap mentaux l'idée est de faire
appel aux cinq sens du corps humain afin
de calmer l'anxiété et le stress que
peut engendrer la maladie colonabule
fibre optique musique douce ou diffuseur
d'huiles essentielles vont permettre de
créer une ambiance agréable et ainsi
détendre les patients je pense que ça
peut apporter beaucoup à des personnes
comme les personnes âgées atteintent
d'Alzheimer qui sont parfois désorientés
ou on des voilà qui sont un peu perdus
ça peut ESS vraiment les aider à se
recentrer je pense que c'est une bonne
chose c'est d'une part un espace où un
espace et un temps où les personnes
peuvent vraiment euh se poser et euh et
ressentir des choses qu'elles ne
ressentent pas forcément des odeurs qui
peuvent leur raeler des des souvenirs et
cetera après il ça aura pas un effet
magique sur sur cette
maladie à l'initiative du groupement
médico-social gérondicap de
Saint-Quentin et avec l'aide financière
du Lyon's club de Montini la méthode
snowzelen d'origine hollandaise n'offre
donc pas de remède miracle à la maladie
elle propose néanmoins plusieurs fois
par par semaine un havre de paix aux
patients pour alléger leur
[Musique]
quotidien ce numéro de checkup touche à
sa fin avant de nous quitter jetons un
coup d'œil sur l'agenda et sur ce qu'il
faut retenir le mois d'octobre est
consacré à la lutte contre le cancer du
sein des dépistages sont proposés dans
tout le département et des événements il
sont organisés du 21 au 25 octobre c'est
la Semaine Bleue la semaine nationale
des retraités et des personnes âgées via
des conférences et des ateliers des
professionnels de la santé donneront
quelques bons conseils pour faciliter la
vie quotidienne checkup c'est terminé
merci de votre attention je vous donne
rendez-vous dans un mois d'ici là
portez-vous
[Musique]
bien